this is jocko podcast number 336 with
echo charles and me jocko willink good
evening echo good evening
so
we've done a lot of
reading and discussions and interviews
on this podcast
about the strategies and tactics
from leadership
from human nature
that i've seen or i've seen others use
or i've used myself
and
you know this is something that i've
noticed lately is and this is something
i used to see in the seal teams
and now i see it at a destination on
front as well where i i can sit there
and discuss something with someone
and think that they understand
how to utilize that lesson immediately
so i explain something to someone and i
think okay cool you know
they get it now right and they'll nod in
their head and they'll kind of even give
me the read back of you know what the
what the principle means
and so i think they get it and it seems
pretty obvious from my vantage point but
but it isn't always that obvious to
everybody and
it can be very hard to see things when
you're observing them for the first time
so
a lot of times i like to try and show a
tactic or a technique or a strategy
or a procedure from a different angle
from a different perspective
and that's you know in order to try and
convey that message to someone
from a different
vantage point where they maybe can
understand it better and i think
i have become biased toward giving
someone else's perspective
someone else's example
and i think that bias comes from the
fact that i already know my perspective
right so i already know what i think so
i i
enjoy
or i want to give someone else's
perspective of a strategy
because
i find it interesting because it's
someone else's because i already know
what's inside my own head right i
already know what's in there
that being said
when i did the first interview i ever
did in my life was with tim ferriss and
he asked me if there's anything that i
was world class at
and of course i said world class is a
very strong
phrase to use right and he said it is a
strong phrase
and i so i told him i didn't think i was
world class at anything which
i
still believe i'm not world class at
anything
but then i don't know if he reframed the
question or if i just kind of reframed
it in a way that i could appropriately
answer it and i said something along the
lines of if i had to say
that i had some skill sets that helped
me
i think that those skill sets would be
number one
being able to take complex things and
make them simple
and then being able to communicate those
things in a simple way that other people
can understand
and then number two
was the ability to detach myself
mentally and emotionally from whatever
situation i'm in
and i believe that allows me to see it
more clearly
so those are the two things that i think
helped me out throughout my career and
that i might be decent at doing
so
i wanted to talk through some principles
that
we reflect on a lot
but in a more pragmatic way uh just to
ensure or at least to help everyone put
some of these principles to use
in our current environment and and i've
also been thinking about talking about
how some of the principles that i talk
about apply to what is going on
today
uh this is not now what i don't want to
do is do some kind of a current events
thing oh this is the latest news story
and this is because i don't
to me that's not that's not
gonna last long right people need if you
use a current day example
that takes some you have to understand
the back story behind this news thing so
you can apply it
i'm not really looking to do that
because i want somebody to be able to
listen to this in six years and say oh
there's a good there's a good angle i
didn't see before and this is going to
help me with my leadership situation
that i'm in right now or it's going to
help me with my life the way i'm in
right now it's going to help me get
through overcome this challenge that i'm
facing right now so to make it a little
bit more evergreen is the term
right am i using what is it industry
terminology evergreen
i learned evergreen from you so oh did
you yes sir evergreen means you can
listen to this podcast in
10 years
and still make sense you're not
referring to some random
you know tmz news story that just came
out and and everybody's hype on it
uh
but
i think we can remain or or maintain
the evergreen
aspect of the podcast
and still put in some some of the
current events that are going on right
now or at least some of the
more outstanding current events and you
know some of this i've done on on
unraveling with daryl cooper i know we
did afghanistan
we've talked about ukraine um you know
so there's things that he and i hid on
that podcast
to
kind of
discuss
from my perspective what's going on with
these situations and even those are
difficult
because they change so rapidly things
change so rapidly and i was just having
a conversation with about about this
with jp this morning about
you know he's heard me say a million
times that the first report
the first report's always wrong
and
he was you know going through a
situation he's like hey is the first
report always wrong i said yeah
well let me rephrase that it might not
be wrong but it also might not be right
but you can't just trust i might need to
modify that a little bit where i say you
can't trust the first report because if
you call me panicked saying i think the
house is on fire right or the house is
on fire the house is on fire
i can't
trust that i have to put it into my
calculus
but look there could have been a smoke
bomb that the teenagers threw through
the window and it looks like the house
on fire but the house isn't on fire yeah
right or the house could be on fire so
it could be right it could be wrong what
i do know about the first report is i
can't trust it 100
it's unreliable it's unreliable so i
might need to
gather
additional information
so
speaking of these topics and speaking of
something that comes up all the time
and that
i call a superpower
is the ability to
detach
and this
some people automatically get
uncomfortable with that because when i
say detach they think oh you told me you
shouldn't have any emotions at all right
and it is talking about detaching from
your emotions
it can also mean physically detaching
from a situation
but detachment is a superpower we'll get
to the emotional thing and how much you
should detach and how much is too much
i think one of the clearest
displays of detachment and how powerful
it is
well one of them i wrote about
leadership strategy and tactics my first
platoon doing the the uh clear and the
oil platform but i had that other
situation
where i was with seth
and we were he was he had taken over his
task under commander
and when he took over his task under
commander he broke his neck
thank god he wasn't paralyzed
so seth stone was my was one of the
platoon commanders and tasked bruiser
now he's took over as the task commander
and he's going through his
pre-deployment workup and i'm in charge
of training for all these seal platoons
and task units getting ready to deploy
and
seth
doing a shipboarding where you climb up
ladders onto ships
from smaller boats
the guy he was the last guy to be
climbing the ladder because he's the the
the tasking commander so he's not gonna
be the first guy on deck right because
he's sort of taking a step back he's
supposed to be detached so he's gonna be
the last guy that goes up and as he's
going up
the person above right let me rephrase
that right as he was about to start
climbing a la the ladder
one of the other guys fell off the
ladder and landed square on top of
seth's head from a fall of about like 20
feet and it broke his
broke his neck his spinal cord was
intact thank god
so now he's in a big neck brace
and
he but he can still walk around and his
his task unit is now going through our
land warfare training and so
he's out there observing because he
can't participate
and as he's participating or as he's
observing and i'm standing with him
observing and it's one of these crazy
training exercises there's total mayhem
going on there's freaking explosions
going off we're using this high speed
laser tag system there's
dead people everywhere again this is
training so they're not actually dead
but they're they're they're uh
their laser tag system is saying that
you're dead
so there's
bodies strewn all over the place and no
one's moving and no one's making any
calls it's a total disaster and they're
in in a ravine
and
the enemy
in quotes is in an elevated position and
they're just tearing up this seth's task
unit and seth he looks at me and said
can i tell him what to do and i said no
i said just let him figure it out
and another 30 seconds go by more guys
get shot with laser tags call the music
let me help them and i go not yet
another 30 seconds go by more guys get
shot
and mind you his guys are in this ravine
we're actually in the ravine with them
now they're kind of prone position or
maybe on their knees and we're standing
up but we're in the ravine with them
and finally
he says more guys get shot he goes can i
let me help him and i go all right go
ahead
and he grabs a random dude not a leader
just a random guy
and he says
i i remembered exactly what he said the
other night he said do i ads which is
which is the most broad
the most broad instruction to give
someone because no one's making any
decisions and an iad is an immediate
action drill
which means when you have a play in
football what's a play in football tell
me like a play right now play that you
guys used to run that you were a part of
38 sweet okay so 38 sweep so now
everybody knows what to do when you call
that give me another one 41 okay 41
sweep now everyone's doing something a
little bit different but we're making
adjustments so you literally have plays
like that
and you would say if you were going to
tell your football team you'd say
call a play right what seth was saying
was do i ads which is the same thing as
saying
call a play so he just grabs a random
dude he's like hey and some probably
some new guy or one cruise wonder like
all freaked out because everyone's
getting shot
and you know seth gets in his face like
do i ads
and the kid
looks up at seth and okay
and he makes a call
whatever whatever
38 sweep or 41 sweep or peel left peel
right shift left shift right whatever
the call was
this kid actually makes a call
and almost immediately
the problem solved right almost
immediately they start executing this
play
and people start putting down cover fire
other people start to move it and it
solves the problem
and as they get out of the area and get
out of the kill zone
seth looks at me and he says it's so
easy to see what to do from way up here
and
let me remind you way up here in that
situation was simply that we were
standing up i mean it wasn't like we
were in some elevated position we didn't
we weren't in an aircraft flying round
over no we could just see a little bit
more
and by the way the position we were in
was a tactically sound position
so
just by looking around
and not getting tunnel vision and
detaching
whatever it is
probably 20 inches higher than the other
people because they're on their knees
and you're standing up so you got like
what maybe two feet of additional
altitude
and you could see everything
and and i looked at him and i said well
i said something wrong look we're not
we're with them we're not way up here
we're 24 inches above them
and he's like oh yeah and i said but
you're looking around you're detached he
says oh yeah and then i said you
remember when we went through this
training and he says yeah and i said
this is what it was like for me all the
time
and he had a look on his face of
sort of
recognition kind of like oh dang
so all the confusion and chaos that was
going on i was always looking at like
okay uh peel left you know shift right
swift what a swing 32 what it was really
easy to make the calls because you're
looking at it and you can see it
and that is the that is the power of
being able to detach
and
it is
you would think that now this is where
this is why i'm talking about this stuff
right now because you think if i explain
that to you
you go okay cool thanks jocko now i'm
getting detached
right
that's what we would hope for yeah
there's a problem it's not that easy
in fact
this can be very difficult to do
so here are some of the mechanics
of
being able to detach
and some of these are a little bit like
training wheels a little bit like
like
learning aids that once you get good at
it you won't need to do it anymore but
you should remember them anyways because
there might be some situations where
[__] really starts going sideways and
you have to go back put your training
wheels on and kind of put get it back
together
so
one of the first training wheels is take
a step back a physical step back
a physical step back this is going to
change your perspective
it changes your spective
perspective
and here's here's a little like a little
a little
extra advice and it's weird to say this
lift your chin up
and look around
and the reason i say lift your chin up
is because
when you lift your chin up you're you're
you're changing your perspective a
little bit right even if it's only by
a half an inch when you lift your chin
up you're kind of opening up your you're
opening up yourself you're opening up to
new ideas
it's the opposite of a fight stance what
do you do in your fight if you're going
to get a fight yeah yeah you put your
chin down you put your hands up
so in this situation
and again this is a this is like a a
non-threatening situation so if i if
you're coming at me if you're like some
kind of hostile or unknown and you're
coming at me and you're confronting me
obviously i'm not going to lift my chin
up and put my hands down
that's totally different what i will do
is keep my chin down lift my hands up i
will step back i will create space so
that i can see more of what's happening
because i don't know you got buddies
you know i don't know
if there's what my surroundings have i
don't know if there's weapons available
to me so i'm going to get my hands up
but i am going to broaden my perspective
broaden my perspective this is and this
is something that we talked about
uh when andrew huben was on here
broadening your perspective opening up
your field of vision
truly
calms you
it calms you down so that's that's one
of the steps of detachment
so take a step back lift your chin look
around and then take a breath a nice
slow breath
because this is another thing that's
going to calm you down it's another
thing that's going to let you get
control over your emotions
and this is something that people
intuitive you remember when you were a
little kid and you'd be having a temper
tantrum
i've seen it done yeah okay when your
kids are having a temper tantrum have
you ever said like hey just take a
breath
and this is something even okay let me
give you a better example you get hurt
or your kid gets hurt and
right yep what do you tell them hey take
a breath calm down like take a breath
that's what we tell people to do that's
crazy how you said that example because
i was watching old videos
of my son like did something he tripped
over it was a funny video but anyway he
at the end of the video he trips over
something falls down i was like what
kind of hit his knee or whatever
same deal and literally played out on
the video but i was just watching that
video so yeah and so did you take a
breath yeah on the video i was like oh i
said breathe i was like breathe breathe
and he's like he's trying to breathe his
foot yeah is it very very appropriate
when hixson was on here hixson wrote a
book yeah called breathe right so
there's a reason for this yeah and it's
it's proven by experience of people that
have been in pressure situations and
it's proven through
doctors who can tell you about the
physiological impact of
taking a nice slow
breath
so that's what we're doing this is going
to help you detach in these pressure
situations
now listen here's another little like a
note
let's say you're let's say you and i
work together and you're pissed off this
is a lot different than you and i don't
know each other and you're confronting
me right that's a self-defense situation
hands are coming up i'm still going to
de-escalate i'm going to step back i'm
going to create space all those things
i'm trying to de-escalate and by the way
i'm trying to get detached as well
because let's say
you know you bumped into or i bumped
into your girlfriend and spilled drinks
on you and now you're all mad yeah right
i don't know you but now you're all mad
you're coming at me
should i escalate my anger cause you're
coming at me or cause you yell a swear
at me and you you push me should i let
my anger get me no
i should not because then bad things are
going to happen
instead i should be
stepping back creating distance looking
around
getting my hands into a
into a defensive yet non-threatening
open aspect towards you
that's what i need to do now if you and
i but that's not a life threat or a
self-defense situation but in just a
normal you and i are talking and you
start getting pissed but you and i work
together
what i'm probably do as i step back as i
take a breath
as i as i broaden my field i'm i'm
probably going to just nod my head and
let you know that i'm listening to what
you're saying and we're going to talk
more about listening
but
that's what i'm going to do
that's what i'm gonna do
and and as i wrote about in extreme
ownership i'm gonna relax look around
make a call that's a that was the
earliest way of me
trying to teach seth how to detach
was me saying me writing on his humvee
window hey things are going wild
step one relax step two look around
step three make a call that's the
earliest sort of version of me trying to
convey this message to someone
i didn't know how to say detach yet
didn't it didn't compute i was just
trying to tell him the physical act of
what to do freaking relax bro
look around see what else is going on
okay now make a call
now
here's the deal on this stuff
you can't see
anything when you're in the thing
you can't see anything when you're in
the thing
and the solution the problem isn't in
the problem and look the there's a mass
shooting that just happened in a school
horrible
i
people keep saying when are you going to
what are you going to say about it i
need to see some after actions reports
i need to find out what happened i don't
know what happened
there's
one of the things that i could tell you
as you train people to handle horrible
situations like that you need to teach
people to detach because if they're not
detached
they can't see the solution to the
problem
all they see is what's right in front of
them
so
if you've got
a shooter an active shooter in a
building
and you go into that building and you
haven't been trained properly you're
gonna get focused on that active shooter
then if you think oh the active shooter
isn't an active shooter shooter anymore
it's a barricaded shooter you're gonna
oh that's a barricaded shooter now i'm
gonna follow this other tactic technique
or procedure because you're focused on
what's right in front of you you're
focused on that piece of information
that you have
and you're not going to take a step back
and go hey what's really happening right
now
who who can give me a report who has
accountability for the students how many
students are there how many are missing
where are they located
who's assembling that big picture you
know who's assembling that big picture
someone that's detached from the
situation
and it is not easy to train people to do
that it used to take me a while to get a
seal
sometimes a seal that been in for five
years seven years ten years
to get them to be able to oh there's
mayhem going on in this building i need
to be the one that takes a step back
looks at the big picture
and and figures out what's actually
happening
the the the
putting people through that advanced
seal tactical training the primary
purpose
with the leaders was for me to get them
to learn how to detach
and again at the time i didn't say it
with these exact words
um you know i'd say you need to step
back and look at the big picture you
know like i would i was trying to convey
it the best i could at the time i might
have used the word detached
but i know i would say things like hey
take a step back look around you need to
see this stuff you need to look at the
big picture that was me trying to get
these young seal leaders
like seth stone
hey dude relax and look around
that's what you need to do
because
once we could get those young seal
leaders to actually do that
all of a sudden they could solve these
complex problems that we would throw out
if they couldn't attach no no if no one
in a platoon detached no one would solve
the problem and they would get
slaughtered
if one person
could take a step back and say oh wait
we shouldn't keep going down this
hallway or we shouldn't keep moving up
this street or we shouldn't keep going
up this ravine or we should we should go
backwards right now or we should flank
them if one person can see that they win
if nobody sees it they get slaughtered
so my primary goal with the leaders
teaching them how to lead the first
thing they had to do is be able to
detach now once you detach then you can
see then you teach them okay here's how
you want to use the terrain here's an
effective way to maneuver here's where
you want to concentrate your forces like
all those things are great
if you can't detach you can't do any of
those things
it's a lot harder than it looks
it's a lot harder than it seems and the
hype and the emotion and the energy it
tends to make us not want to detach
and
the natural tendency that we have as
human beings is to focus on what's right
in front of us
this is the natural tendency
that's how we survived as
hunter-gatherers
as a hunter-gatherer you either okay if
you're a hunter guess what you got to be
focused on you see movement and it's a
freaking
pig that you're going to slaughter kill
with a bow and arrow or spear or
whatever you need to hyper focus on that
thing as an individual human you need a
hyper focus on that thing
if you're
walking around and you see movement and
it's a tiger
you need to focus on that thing it needs
to become your number one priority
in order to survive you need to focus
you need to get hyper focused and that's
what we're programmed for and there's
sometimes as an individual you got to do
that sometimes it's actually a a great
thing to have
you know you're walking down the street
and all of a sudden the car is coming up
on the sidewalk you focus on that thing
so you can avoid it you've think of you
never seen that uh like when they're
trying to get a robot to like catch a
ball
it has to do 8 billion calculations in
0.2 seconds to catch a ball i don't even
know if a i don't know if there's a
there's a robot that can catch like a a
fastball from a from a pitcher yeah like
a humanoid robot yeah like a humanoid
robot even one with the size like a with
a with a glove the size of a catcher's
mitt or like a i can almost guarantee
you that they can't make one that could
hit a baseball bat
i don't know i've never seen one if
that's uh yeah there's a billion little
calculations that have to get made
and i've also heard like baseball
players when that when the when the ball
leaves the pitcher's
hand like they're already
predicting where it's going to be i mean
obviously they are because they can hit
it with a freaking skinny little bat you
know what i'm saying
so
so there's times where this is fully
beneficial and that's what our that's
what our natural tendency is is to get
focused on this thing that's right in
front of us but as leaders
and honestly in some situations as
individuals you're going to have a
problem if you do that uh
well and i think i was thinking about
this from 100 right but
it mostly has to do when you're dealing
with humans when you're dealing with a
human threat because humans because
humans do coordinated attacks yeah right
sure like oh
a wolf
oh you might get attacked by a pack of
wolves
you'll lose just because they all attack
you at the same time
uh you might get eaten by a pack of
sharks
but it's not because one distracted you
and the other one snuck up you know what
i'm saying there's a difference between
mob attacks which i think is what most
animals do
and
what humans do which is humans are
setting you up like a sucker and
flanking you right that's what humans do
that's what uh
that's what like a sucker punch is right
oh soccer punch is like oh you're there
talking to me and i'm like i'll beat you
and boom my buddy punches you in the
side of the head or hit you with a
bottle from behind that's what humans do
humans are savages
and so even as individuals sometimes if
you get target fixation you're going to
have a problem
so
when we're in complex situations it
could be an emergency right emergency a
fire
uh a vehicle accident there's a lot of
stuff going on combat situations
obviously
and you know what else
this is where you make that mental
transition
an argument with someone yeah maybe not
even argument but a debate with someone
have you ever seen someone get lured in
an argument and just flanked yeah and
it's because they didn't detach
uh
a few good men yes right that whole
thing is just a big flank right i'm
going to get this guy so mad and so
emotional that when i ask him this
question he's going to expose himself
and that's what tom cruise
does right you're god damn right i
ordered the code red that's exactly what
he does
the colonel
in that movie
jack nick jack nicholson nicholson yes
sir jack nicholson he didn't detach no
he could have seen through that so
easily
he could have been like no i i
absolutely would not order that if you
imagine if he was calm yeah he didn't
that's a perfect example of how we can
let this
idea
bite us yeah so if
perhaps
what's the colonel's name in that movie
jessup colonel if if colonel jessup
maybe if he would have gone through my
land warfare training back in the day
i'm like oh i'm about to get flanked by
homeboy by young tom cruise
colonel jessup would have said actually
no negative there's no way i'd give that
order but instead he got emotional he
got flanked like a little punk
so
imagine
how much that happens to us or can
happen to us
so that's what we have to learn how to
do
in everything and here's a little
connection i'm going to make for you
there's a connection between
being humble and being able to detach
mm-hmm
and the connection is
if you're not humble if you've got a big
ego you think you're the center of the
world
right you think you're you think you are
the center of the world
and when you think you're the center of
the world you can't see anyone else's
emotions you can't see anyone else's
moves their moves don't even mean
anything to you because you're just
looking at
everything is
jocko centric eco-centric
it's all about me so i don't see that
you're getting mad i don't see that
you're getting frustrated
and that's what we have to be careful
about
because
if you think you're the most important
thing
and you've got that gravity
it's pulling everything in
and and and all like other ideas
then they don't make it
other
nothing else can survive this strong
gravity that you got you don't see
anything else
what's the difference between detaching
and situating you know let's say
situational awareness right what's i
mean is there a difference
they're
they're uh if they're not the same thing
then they're damn close yeah i would say
actually i would i would say this
detachment is senior to
situational awareness if you don't if
you're not detached you're not gonna
have any situational awareness
if you are detached you will have much
more situational awareness detachment is
senior because
not only am i detached so i can see
what's happening in the situation i'm
also aware of my emotions i'm aware of
your emotions
does the situation include everything
okay then they're probably the same
thing if we're saying that situation
overall includes your emotions my
emotions our physical space that we're
in everything that's occurring if that's
the situation okay then they're they're
probably pretty close to the same thing
i i generally think of situational
awareness as to being what's our
physical thing that's happening but it's
not too much to different to say oh echo
is a
a possible attacker yeah yeah is he
agitated yeah that would be situational
awareness oh i can see he's frustrated i
can see he's his fists are clenched okay
that's all situational awareness so
they're really similar things
but i i think
i still think detachment is a senior
element yeah because if you don't have
detachment it ain't happening you're not
gonna have situational awareness at all
yeah it feels like most of the time
sitting with it you bring up detaching
is when you're kind of in
when the chaotic situation kind of
already started you know where it's
almost like
i guess you can constantly be detached
though right i mean not completely like
how you say i mean you know every time i
heard you explain it you're like don't
go too far with this thing right you
don't care about nothing or whatever but
uh
seems like detaching when i imagine it i
guess is yeah when something like
happens to kind of escalate or whatever
and then it's like okay then you should
kind of detach or whatever and you know
what there's a good point check this out
the the black belt
he's likely not even gonna get the
situation to a point where he has to
detach because he's already attached and
he sees it coming and doesn't have to
worry about it because he already
outflanked it that's the game that's the
game that's what we're trying to do
mm-hmm
unless he's going up against another
black belt unless he's going up until he
gets another black belt then thus begins
the psychological game within the game
yeah and then you end up in straight
jujitsu where how many moves ahead
you know mi yeah to you am i five moves
ahead and you're only four i'm gonna win
if i'm five moves ahead but you're seven
you're gonna win
that's what's happening
so
there is a connection between the more
self-centered we are
the less the rest of the world matters
and therefore it's hard to step outside
of your own world yeah maybe that's a
better way of putting it yeah that seems
accurate you know uh for instance a
little kid that loses their temper yeah
why is that because they're they're the
whole world in the store in the store
they don't care about anything else they
want that freaking ice cream cone that's
what's that's what's up so they don't
care about anything else yeah and
they're not going to be able to detach
at all yeah and they don't care about
anything else that's when so the younger
you are you're really important
so we have to be careful with that
here's another
little element
detachment is what actually allows you
to think strategic
it's what actually allows you to think
strategic because
the the definition of of what i started
with of saying hey i'm worried about the
person that's shooting me right now
that's short-term thinking now do i have
to focus on that right now cause i'm
getting shot at yes i do
the minute i eliminate that threat i
better take a step back and look around
and get my platoon into position where i
don't have to worry about threats so i
can see where we need to go next
so
unless we are detached unless you take a
minute you know if you're in business
and every day you show up to work the
phone's ringing the emails are coming in
you're solving this problem for a client
you're dealing with operations you're
dealing with sales you've got all these
problems you're just that's what you're
doing all day
cool
but you're not detached and therefore
you're thinking about tactical things
that are right in front of you and you
might win the day tactically but you
look up in six months and you've
you've got some issues because you
didn't order enough material for the
next project and you didn't hire
like all these problems are happening
strategic problems are happening
so unless you're able to detach you're
not able to think strategic
so think about how this impacts your
life i mean this is
this is you know from you echo charles
you you've said before to me
that the most important thing that
you've taken away from hanging out with
me for the last however many years
is thinking
strategic instead of tactical well and
the way that translates to the civilian
world is you think long term instead of
short term
and i agree with you and we have a
uh you've heard me say before and you
pulled a clip from one of the uh musters
where a guy asked me you know how often
should i think strategic and i said you
should think strategic all the time yeah
you said it different but yeah yeah i
was a little a little more amped at the
time but
if you can't detach if you don't take a
step back you are not thinking strategic
yeah that's why this is like a
superpower detachment
allows you to not focus on the short
term it avoids tactical thinking now it
also avoids you getting emotional and
making bad decisions because that's when
you make bad decisions are you
guaranteed to make a bad decision where
you're emotional no
but
i mean there's a real good chance pretty
reliable yeah it's pretty reliable that
an emotional decision is not the best
decision
it's pretty reliable
now
does this mean i'm sitting there saying
it for everyone that's you know uh out
there going oh you know
you're saying you shouldn't have any
emotions that's actually not what i'm
saying at all what i'm saying is
you shouldn't let your emotions run
your decisions
control over your emotions does not mean
not having emotions
because emotions
are important
we like to say yes sir emotions are
important
um
my emotions are important
my team's emotions are important my
boss's emotions are important
the competitor or the enemy emotions are
important
and i okay how can they be important
well if i if you're mad about something
that you need to do are you going to do
a good job if you work for me are you
going to do your best job
if on the contrary if you're super
excited about something are you going to
do a good job yeah what if you're my
enemy and your morale is low and you're
emotionally drained is it going to be an
opportune time to fight you yes it is
what if you're
what if i've done something to your
people and now you're mad and you're
gonna fight with vengeance you're angry
is is that a good time for me to attack
you if my you're my enemy
no
what about my boss my boss is
super angry about something is now a
good time to present a new solution to
no
is that like the old classic um don't
tell your wife to calm down that is part
of the classic don't tell your wife to
calm down because like yeah she's not
she's emotional whatever and vice versa
this isn't you know but the uh yeah when
you say hey
calm down
that's not a good move
that's not a strategic
so you can see how emotions play into
each one of those elements that i just
talked about yeah so i have oh by the
way i have to know my emotions too right
if i've got some
massive task
and i know i'm already
drained or angry about it if i've got
some delicate if i'm mad at you and yet
i've got to go and discuss a project
with you yeah and i'm already mad that
you didn't do something is that a good
time for me to go in there and talk to
you no it's not so
what i need to do
and a way to think the emotions
our own emotions and other people's
emotions up down across the chain of
command need to be in the calculus of
our decision making
that's what i need to do and a lot of
times in current times
this is 20 22
we don't take other people's emotions
into our calculus
so
you have to measure
you have to measure if
and how
what you are going to say
how it's going to impact your family if
it's going to impact your family or team
yourself you have to measure that
is it going to make them angry is it
going to make them upset is it going to
make them lose motivation is it going to
crush their morale
and if you don't put that if you don't
put all the emotional element into the
calculus you're going to get the wrong
answer
and by the way
you won't be able to assess any of these
emotions if you're not detached
you won't see
your own emotions you won't see other
people's emotions you won't be like oh
my wife is mad right now because you're
mad
so you don't see them as being mad and
even if you do see them as being mad
you're mad so you just get mad at them
for being mad what you have to do is be
able to detach and get some level of
control over your emotions
so
when when i talk about detaching from
your emotions i'm not talking about
having no emotions and by the way
if you detach from your emotions too
much
and now you're interacting with your
team your team just thinks you're a jerk
that's that's what's happening
so
yeah yeah like you don't care oh yeah
like a big deal oh that's a huge deal
like when your boss doesn't care or is
it distracted or just when you have that
feeling is what i'm saying yeah yeah or
if you give that feeling to your wife oh
yeah you know something that you're
talking about to me this is all you're
talking about it's like the because that
kind of is the deal right where you like
you lit every single list item or
everything every topic you talked about
literally has directly to i mean look
some people not married i get it
but if you are even girlfriend boyfriend
scenario whatever
that applies to you and your wife 100 oh
yeah it's like and your kids so the kids
there's
you explain yeah
it's more like i don't know it's like it
is the same thing it's the same format
for sure but and you explain this too
where it's like your kids are gonna be
different than like other people because
when you have kids that's a very unique
relationship it's very unique they're
like you can't
you can't just switch out one kid for
another kid
and
make the connection you're so close to
me what's the connection the emotions
the emotions yeah connections that's
what makes it
you know your emotional attachment to
your kids
is so strong
it's so strong
that you have to be even
more
cautious
in how you
and how you calculate the emotions up
and down the chain so it's kind of like
the difference between a muffin and a
cupcake but i don't know the difference
between those two it's the same thing
one just has more sugar in it
is that the truth i don't know which one
has more sugar cupcake
okay you see what i'm saying yeah
i guess the kids have more sugar they
have more emotions more emotions
but you handle them the same way right
try not to eat them you know 80 to 90
percent of the time seem insane yep yep
so
you can't see any of these emotions if
you're not detached so go back to first
topic of the day take a step back relax
look around take a breath
get detached and then put the emotions
comprehend the emotions put them into
your calculus as you're making decisions
as you're communicating with people and
that's going to put you in a different
put you in a better scenario
now here's another thing that you can
utilize
[Music]
for detachment
which is very powerful not just for
detachment but for life and definitely
for leadership
and that is actually listening to what
other people are saying
and i've been saying for a couple years
now listening is the most underrated
skill in leadership
and
i i think
i have to take it a little bit further
and i was thinking about a good way to
explain listening because listening
doesn't just mean be quiet okay echo's
talking now as soon as you're done i'm
ready to present my ideas back at you
i don't know where we did this i think
we probably just did this on a q a q a a
while ago but people have
often asked me what is my process for
reading a book
and i've talked through my process for
reading a book and reading a book for
the podcast really
so if i'm reading a book from the
podcast
i'm gonna read it
actively
it's an active
reading i'm not passively the words
aren't just coming into my head and
there they are and
no i'm actively reading the words that
means i am putting the words into
context in my own head
in the story that it is
and then how my mind
understands that story and what the
context in the story is and then how
that context fits in my head because
let's face it if i'm reading with the
old breed
there's context to that story to that
particular sentence that particular
paragraph that particular word there's
context around it and it's not just a
word and it's not just a sentence it's
not just a paragraph there's a whole
there's a whole world there
that you have to try and understand this
context that you have to have and then
you have to put it into your own
context and look you don't have to have
been in combat to understand
or to or to put your own context around
it you go oh
these guys haven't eaten
for six days
hey i remember yesterday
i didn't have any lunch and by the end
of the day i was starving god now these
guys aren't successful i'm saying you
have to really try and engage your own
brain and
overlay your own experiences on it
and try and understand and truly put
yourself into other people's perspective
what what do they know that that that i
can try and understand so so to me
that's active reading
really active reading
and that's what we need to do with
listening
actively listen actively try and
understand
what you're trying to say actively try
and understand your perspective what
does echo know that i don't know right
now how can i actively try and
understand what he's saying
and of course one of the biggest
obstacles
to truly listening is having a big giant
ego and i think echo don't know what
he's talking about you know what i mean
like oh hey jonko you know i always put
my arm over i always put my hips over
here on an arm like oh echo's trying to
give me instructions on jiu-jitsu yeah
yeah you know what i'm saying that's
what
our ego gets in the way because how
could anybody possibly know anything
more than me
so we don't really listen
and i think
i think
that as we look at society today
there is a lot of talking and not a lot
of listening
and it turns into mayhem
and here's the thing
talking no listening and therefore no
no bridges no common ground found no
changes of opinion people don't change
opinion
right i got my opinion i'm right i'm not
going to change my opinion that's where
people are at that's where the vast
majority of people are at seems like
yeah
well i shouldn't even say the vast
that's where the loudest people are at
i guess it's worth saying yeah
yeah
um i i think it's an issue
i think it's it's a huge issue i think
it's an issue for myself you mean a lot
like a lot of times an issue for
everybody myself yourself everybody
that's everybody that's in the world
is hey i kind of know the deal here yeah
i know this you know you're not going to
tell me anything that i don't know yeah
and and what's horrible about that is
you know if you were presenting a plan
to me for an operation
and i have a difference of opinion than
you and so i and but i don't listen to
what you're saying are we going to come
up with a better plan or a worse plan
probably worse yeah it's going to be a
worse plan whereas if i go oh echo's
presenting a plan to me let me truly
actively listen to what he's saying
let me see how that fits into the idea
that i have and where's the common
ground and what oh and we got some
contradictory ideas okay cool
who's right and you know what i actually
say how is echo right um that's the
biggest trick right there when it comes
to leadership one of the biggest tricks
in leadership is how is echo right i'm
the leader but how is echo right how can
i make echo right how can i listen to
him how can i make him how can i give
him the the
the advantage here
not how can i prove him wrong i don't
want you to be wrong i want you to be
right yeah
so
that's what we have to do now when we
listen just like reading
when we actively listen we actively read
ask yourself
or ask them and yourself earnest
questions
put yourself in their shoes in real life
this is hard to do
in real life in real life
truly how would i feel if i were that
person and you know sometimes like uh
you know
echo
uh
let's see echo
didn't pay for his phone he got his
phone cut off right so i go
what a loser
like he
i
he he's an idiot he deserves it yeah
that's as far like oh well okay if i was
in echo shoes and i didn't pay my phone
bill and it got caught off i would think
i was a loser that's like my perspective
instead of saying all right what's the
situation he's in
how did he end up here what doesn't he
understand about the world that i
understand
how come he doesn't understand those
things
that's what that's what it is it's like
it takes effort yeah
it takes effort to get there instead of
just writing it off and i put i take my
entire world view
and i take your little chunk of
experience that you had by not paying
your phone bill and i go oh in my world
view you're a loser
that's true
and so then what what how can i help you
i can yeah i can't help you i can't help
myself i can't help anybody else all i
say is oh anyone that does that's a
loser right
doesn't solve anything
so that that's what i think is a is a
huge
a huge
piece for us
is
as a leader and as a person
and look those two terms for me are kind
of interchangeable i don't know that
sounds crazy
but as
this is something that i started saying
i think when leadership strategy and
tactics came out which is
if you interact with other human beings
yeah you're in a leadership position
yeah it doesn't matter if it doesn't
matter if you it doesn't matter if
you're the boss yeah and i'm the
subordinate
and i'm the only subordinate you have
i'm still in a leadership position yeah
it doesn't matter if i have one peer
and
we and i don't see you even though
you're the boss and i have one period
i'm still in a leadership position
if you interact with other people you're
in a leadership position because you're
trying to lead them
to do the right thing
to move in the right direction and does
this mean you're always like trying to
influence yeah no because i might be
like oh echoes give me some direction it
seems like a good call cool i'm gonna go
execute it i don't need like well hold
on let me give you my perspective no no
i'm not talking about that at all am i
trying to build a relationship with you
yes i am
am i trying to build a relationship so
that i can better support you in the
future if you happen to tell me
something to do that doesn't make sense
sure
yeah it's good that you differentiate
pretty often to the difference between
the and what you call the traditional
leader
and you know what and what but what's
the other one you don't have a term for
the other one oh no i certainly do the
silent leader silently yeah right now so
okay so
in even though you don't talk about that
part we just we just mentioned like um
but usually it's kind of like
uh the silent leader is more of like
certain of
maybe influencer type not influencer
like how we know it today but uh like
you know someone who just wants to
influence people to do the right thing
for everybody essentially right and then
the traditional leader is the guy who
wants to be the boss and wants everyone
to listen to what they said everyone
listened to me yeah which is the
opposite of everything i just talked
about which i'm saying if you're a
leader you'd be listening yes exactly
right but i think that even the word
leader and i've said this before where
the word leader feels like it the like
the boss that because there are people
yeah it feels like
yeah and because there's people like
that like we all know somebody at least
one person probably you know 20 people
who are like that where it's like yeah
you can tell they want to always take
charge they want they always want people
to listen to them they always want to do
it their way you know kind of thing and
you know for better worse or whatever
it's i'm just saying that that's when
you think of the word leader
that's kind of what you think of
automatically in one way or the other
absolutely that's one of the
one of the i guess long-term campaigns
for me as a human being on earth is to
convince people and and let them know
that even if you're a brand new guy in a
sealed platoon you're in a leadership
position a brand new guy with no
experience here in a leadership position
even if you're a brand new construction
worker with no experience you're in a
leadership position
even if you're a lineman
out there you're an apprentice lineman
you have no skills
you're in a leadership position
so of the four laws of here's the thing
there's no escaping unless you're a
hermit you're a leader right so there's
no escaping it unless there may be a
newborn baby i don't know
but
and this is this is
this is what i gathered you know
listening to you guys so you know the
the fourth law caught that right
decentralized command as we know as
decent
and the what is that the tagline or
whatever everybody leads right so even
if you are the leader
designated across the you're the boss
either you're the buy at a company or
whatever you're the dad of the family
whatever whatever
you were the straight-up
boss
but decentralized command was loss of
combat says everybody leads so even the
people who are subordinate to you quote
unquote they have to lead and whose job
is it for for them to know how to lead
your job yeah
so
everyone's a leader no matter if you're
the boss or not like you can be the new
guy whatever and most of us are aren't
the new guy in the seo platoon i'll tell
you that
you may or may not know that but some
most of us are not but like if you're
just the new guy at work or you're the
youngest brother or you know you're the
you know i
i've heard and i have this scenario i'm
going to call it hypothetical even
though it might not be hypothetical it's
not me that's true but if someone has
some people i know
where
the husband feels a little bit um
what do you call it like emasculated
sometimes
and not by any abuse or anything like
that but it's just i think it's like a
classic case of um you know what you
hear like the husband's always trying to
like happy wife happy life kind of a
thing and maybe went too far with it and
maybe now he finds himself in a position
where he's like he's just responding and
doing everything that the wife says the
wife doesn't seem happy kind of a
scenario
i feel like with this attitude that like
if you understand 100
100 not just like my situation sure i
guess i could
if you understand 100 that you are
essentially you have the responsibility
to be the leader and i'm not saying be
the boss i'm not saying
it always feels like
that
ends up being absolutely correct
as far as pro solving any problems
within any interpersonal relationship
so
let me just restate you your
your comment there what you're saying is
no matter where i am
in a relationship in a platoon in a
business in a marriage
if my attitude is
um i'm in a leadership position and i'm
going to lead through this problem
that leader that's going to be a
positive thing yes sir yeah you are
correct absolutely like it's that that's
why at ashland front that's why we say
leadership is the solution yes and it
doesn't matter what the problem is yeah
uh
wife's not happy leadership problem on
on me by the way yeah on me now look
could
can you occasionally get
a miserable scenario yeah where oh the
wife is well there's probably and
actually what you end up there is if you
if you break that down from a leadership
perspective you're probably not aligned
in your marriage
because
that's the one kind of killer
there's one that's one killer so
when i say leadership is a solution
leadership is a solution all your
problems there's one problem
that leadership
is the solution for but you're not going
to solve the problem that is
alignment that is we are not going to
the same place yeah so
if your
business partner is going in one
direction like to a different place and
you're going in another direction and
it's a different place you're gonna have
a really you won't be able to make
decisions
that
are unified
if your wife
you know if your wife wants to uh
you know have
20 kids
and you don't want to have any
you're not going to be you're not going
to be able to work it out there's no
working that out right you are heading
to a different place you're going to a
different world yeah right you're going
to two totally different
places vice versa is true too you want
to wait would i say your wife one has 20
kids if it's the opposite it's the same
thing
you you want to have 20 kids your wife
doesn't have any you're going to have a
problem
it's going to be a difficult situation
you're probably you're not aligned
if
one person wants to have a software
company
and i want to you know you and i start
designing a little computer game thing
and then you say
hey we should start building these in a
factory after we make three of them by
ourselves and i say no let's just
contract someone do that we should just
make the software
and you go no no we should make the
hardware and i say no we should make the
software and if you and i can't agree
we're heading to do different places
we're gonna have two different companies
and you need to go do yours and i need
to go do mine
so where leadership plays into that is i
need to be able to identify
where are we actually going what is our
goal
and here's the thing in most companies
you can find alignment that's why people
say we're not aligned i go oh hold on a
minute
oh you got a company you know you got
acme freaking
mouse traps right yeah
echo's got acme mouse traps
and he says oh people on my team aren't
aligned okay what do they not want to be
able to make money
no of course they want to make money do
they do they does everyone on the team
want to make money yes everyone on the
team wants to make money does everybody
on the team want to make a good
mousetrap yes everybody on the team
wants to make good mousetrap does
everyone want to serve the client yes
because if we serve the client we'll
sell them mousetraps
so you can usually find you can take any
company
and most of the 99 this is a big
percentage
99 of the time there's alignment and in
rare one percent
we're not aligned
and you actually don't want to
make mousetraps or you don't want to
manufacture mousetraps let's say i want
to build a factory and manufacture
mousetraps and all you want to do is
market them and you don't want any of
this factory stuff you don't want to
hire a bunch of people you just want to
get them shipped from overseas you're
not going to have a problem
we're not aligned
i want to build a manufacturing company
you want to build a marketing company
and
we're adamant about it now look we might
be able to find alignment and say hey
you know what if we build manufacture
them and then you market them well we
kind of on the same page
but if your true goal is not to
manufacture anything and my true goal is
to we're going to have a problem
so alignment
is
the one of the most critical things
there are in order to get there guess
what i got to listen to what you have to
say
yeah
and if we're not aligned we're going to
have a problem
so we got to pay attention to that
and and this this brings me to the last
thing i wanted to talk about today um
and this is something you know of
i probably use it i probably focused on
it a little bit more a few years ago
with a simple statement that you'll
recognize when i say this free your mind
right we had we had we did all kinds of
things where i said free your mind i i'm
occasionally like post like free your
mind true
because our mind our minds tend have a
tendency
to be closed
and not just to be closed but to be
closing
so that's the way our human minds are in
general
they tend to be closed and closing so
they're already closed up and they're
trying to close even more why is that
well it's safer yeah
it's it's easier yeah i'm i'm not
learning anything there's no risk
there's nothing to misunderstand it's
just easier across the board if i just
close up my mind i don't have to accept
anything new i'm safe here i'm used to
it
we also have our ego involved
and our ego
is is keeping that mind shut because i
don't want to have to admit that i'm
wrong
i don't want to
have to tell anybody else that they're
right
i don't want to look like i don't know
all the answers so i stay in my own
little world
you know it's like oh i'm a boxer so i'm
not going to do jiu jitsu
remember those days like no boxing oh
you try and take me out i was gonna
knock you out yeah remember those days
yeah like it's crazy talk now but that
was a real thing
well i don't have to learn jiu-jitsu
i'll just knock you out yeah oh okay
how'd that work out bro
but that's a closed mind and that's ego
thinking oh i don't need to learn
anything new
i have all the answers oh i got i got
the uppercut son and no look i love
boxing boxing is an awesome form of
self-defense that everybody should learn
how to box you should absolutely learn
how to box
there's two you know your your fists are
great weapons
you should also learn muay thai because
your elbows and your knees are good
weapons as well
you should also learn wrestling because
you got to be able to so you see where
i'm going with this but
there was a time where
strikers boxers kickboxers
would say oh i don't need to learn
jujitsu cause
i'll just knock you out and that was
just arrogance and ego
and and part of it is also might have
been just uh ignorance not just
arrogance but ignorance yeah because
because you think oh someone's gonna
charge at me i'll just knock them out
yeah man it's so much harder than you
think yeah i'm sure there was a lot to
that there was there's a thing called
sunk cost fallacy oh for sure for sure
so yeah the and that's what horan gracie
one of the
founders of jiu-jitsu um
that's what he would say where it's like
it's a re it's a painful realization
when you realize that you spent 20
sometimes 30 years at this in
effortful just hard work you know
training heart yeah and then without it
being proved to you like you're not
going to admit that it was a mistake you
just can't do it you have too much
investigate in it you know yeah that was
that was a very
you want to talk about a very
hard thing to have happen to you yeah is
you've been training
whatever martial art whatever and they
use this do they still use the term
traditional martial art yes so you've
been training a traditional martial art
take your pick for 24 years and like you
said hard training you've memorized the
kata oh yeah you've done the drills
you've done the the
the sparring even
and then so you're you're 20 years deep
25 years deep you've competed even
competed and you've you've knocked
people out and stuff and you've won
you've been a champion all these things
and then all of a sudden someone comes
in and says
none of that's going to work
yeah in a real you know and by the way
it's it's going to work what i do is
going to work 10 times out of 10. like
that's what that's what my percentages
are so you're a you're a you're a boxer
and i'm a jiu jitsu guy
i'm going to take you down and choke you
10 times in a row
it seems unbelievable right they go a
hundred times maybe someone gets a lot
it gets a puncher's chance and someone
gets knocked out right
but
i can i can
law of averages say you're a 100 boxer
and i'm a jiu jitsu guy
10 times out of ten so if you you and i
go okay cool let's go again you try and
knock me out you're getting taken down
you're getting choked let's go again
you're getting you try and knock me out
you're gonna get take down choked out
that's what's happening
so
that was a really hard
fact to face yeah and it happened it
happened across the country as jiu jitsu
blue belts yeah blue belts were dojo
storming like walking into
walking into traditional martial arts
studio i'll take anybody in here yeah
and then double leg double leg you know
cross side people even know what the
guard was it wasn't like they were
getting in the guard they were just
mounting and choking yeah
yeah and that and that was kind of the
especially i mean nowadays is different
because it's totally different you know
like
and here's kind of in a way it's kind of
more the same though right where we're
okay so you look at the ufc right the
pinnacle of like nowadays it's not ufc
one is different than ufc now oh so ufc
one was this art style versus yeah this
style versus this stuff actually you
know what you're right it wasn't just
style versions it was art versus art
yeah because even in jujitsu we have
different styles of jiu jitsu yeah
that's true too so it was literally a
jiu jitsu practitioner against a boxer
right or a wrestler
against an aikido guy yeah or whatever
you name it was art against art oh yeah
and they didn't even really calculate
the fact that
there's a huge difference between
somebody that wrestled in high school
somebody that wrestled in college and
somebody that wrestled in the olympics
or someone that did judo at the judo
club someone that did judo
in college and someone that did judo on
the olympic stage there's a huge
difference between but they didn't
really calculate that yeah not really um
and and i guess i'm just maybe speaking
on what actually played itself out right
so ufc one and before ufc one
there was
gracie in action the gracie and action
tapes right which was essentially
one-on-one challenge wait i have james's
james if you're out there listening
right now i have your gracie in action
tapes sorry
where it's like and if you don't know
what that is what it what it is is
essentially um guys would come in
doubting the this new jiu-jitsu thing um
they're like oh i would beat them you
know and the graces they would say yeah
you can come and challenge any one of
our guys or whatever and then after so
many people responded to that challenge
they started taping it and they would
just beat these guys up not bad it
wasn't a bully situation it was
literally like to prove to them that hey
this way is better at fighting that's it
it's not like yo we're going to kill
everyone or nothing like that
so just time after time at a time and
then if you see it um you can see the
guy and this is on a bunch of them too
where the guy would be like oh um like
almost like he's saying that didn't
count yeah like he didn't get it yeah i
i have personally experienced that oh
yeah that's a common thing yeah i was
lucky because i was doing jiu jitsu kind
of like legitimately doing jiu jitsu
before it was popular at all yeah so i
kind of had some of those gracie in
action experiences where guys were just
confused yeah like just legitimately and
i found that
usually
three or four submissions
before they even start to comprehend
what's happening like the first one
they're just baffled you know you you're
going against the wrestler you're going
against a boxer
wrestlers would get especially confused
because it just didn't make sense of
what just happened like a boxer i guess
a boxer would be so confused they're
like wait what are we doing on the
ground what why am i down there is this
fighting this isn't fighting how can you
knock me out when we're oh they just you
just got your arm broke or you just got
tapped out
wrestlers would be it would be confusing
to them because they don't even
understand how
these body positions that they've
learned and that they've won
and that they seem to have so much
control all of a sudden they're not
working and they're getting tapped out
but yeah so like the first submission is
total disbelief they're like it's
confusion and disbelief and then okay
let's go again because they think oh i i
will keep my uh i won't let them grab my
arm yeah exactly exactly and they don't
let you grab their arm and then you
choke them yeah and that's how how horn
describes it um in those in a lot of
those videos is it's like you can't they
can't accept it right so they're so
they'll be like oh wait i just need to
go harder like
maybe it was taking it easy on him maybe
i got to focus a little bit more you
know go faster go harder yeah exactly
right um
but
just like i said if you don't know
jiu-jitsu if you don't know the
positions you're just sort of on the
ground like you don't know like even
like the difference between garden and
half guard if you don't know what it is
that even is there's no there's no
difference between guard mount nothing
there's no difference you will not
remember it you have no idea remember if
you're on the bottom you'll remember
versus if you're not on the bottom okay
there is that but in jiu jitsu that part
doesn't matter as much you see i'm
saying so it's backwards almost if you
know jiu-jitsu versus if you if you um
if you don't so these guys would be just
confused the whole time and then all of
a sudden they're getting choked and then
if you don't know how it happens you
just like oh we just sort of wound up
like that so it seems kind of like a
lucky position we fell on the ground it
was a scramble and he just you know
ended up that way meaning meanwhile
since they know they knew jujitsu
they're methodically specifically
placing these guys in this position then
this position then this position then
they can joke and then they do it every
like one time after another and after
another now and then finally the guy
accepts it now and you this is back in
the gracie and action days so ufc one
you don't have that luxury to be like
hey let's do it again yeah but still
nobody knew what was going on what was
happening
now keep in mind the difference between
back then and today is back then no new
jiu-jitsu at all they only knew their
karate they only knew their um you know
kickboxing they only knew their art
now everyone knows everything yeah it's
totally in one way or another like if
you say hey show me mountain probably of
course that's basic everyone knows
everyone
this can be literally a karate guy yeah
like remember lyoto mashida right when i
was like oh see karate does work and all
the crowded guys were like yeah
we were saying this for years we always
knew karate right yeah bro yoda
machida's black belt
yeah and he's probably black belt level
in a bunch of other things you know so
it's just a different landscape that's
not the proving ground from for art
versus art anymore yeah it's different
well even i just made people mad just
now three minutes ago when i said well
a boxer against there's still some
people out there that are like bro just
knock this dude out when he came in on
me there's still people like that right
now even having the the incredible vast
source of knowledge and again i i love
boxing everyone should train boxing 100
boxing is a brutal martial art
and
it's an incredible martial art
but if you're a pure boxer and you're
going up against a jiu jitsu guy
you're gonna get choked out i i regret
to inform you
so here's the thing
this is why
i talk about opening up your mind
because even when you choke someone
their mind doesn't want to open up you
then you arm lock them their their mind
doesn't want to open up then you
foot lock them their mind still they're
still thinking like what you're saying
they're still like no
their mind this is such a good example
of how people's minds how all of our
minds
wants to be closed because our ego's
keeping it shut we want to be in that
safe area we've got the sunk cost into
what we've already done and what we
already believe
and that is a problem it's a problem for
the world so what we have to do and i've
been explaining this to people
for at echelon front i've been
explaining this to people we actually
have to pry open our minds
we have to pry open our minds you have
to be you have to force yourself to
listen you have to force yourself not
just to listen but to actually hear
what other people are saying
you have to
force yourself to consider other ideas
and honestly the way that i force myself
to
consider other ideas is i want to use
your idea
that's my goal my goal is i want echo to
be right when echo says hey i've got a
plan for how to do this my goal is to
say that sounds good
let's use your plan how can i help you
make this work
when my subordinate comes to me with a
plan and says hey jungle this is what i
think we should do my goal is to use it
when you present an idea to me about
uh politics or music or a video my goal
is to say okay
how can i be on board with what you just
said
how can i how can i support you
and that's what i do to try and pry my
brain open
because our minds
are naturally closed and they are
closing so even when your mind gets
opened up a little bit it's still trying
to close back up that's what it's trying
to do it's pride open and it closes back
up that's what it's trying to do we have
to work very hard to pry it open and
then keep it open to new ideas
you know how like we in regards to like
using the other person's plan or you
know like pursuing that is like a as a
way
how does that
oh should i say how does that justify
you know because you know how sometimes
and again i'm thinking about maybe with
your friends when you're young or you
know with your wife or something and
it's like hey what are we doing for
dinner or where are we going to go eat
and then it's like i don't know where do
you want to go i don't know where you
want right you get that scenario it
happens sometimes right
so how do you
reconcile using the other person's plan
in general versus
making the decision yourself kind of a
scenario no i mean
look just like anything there's a
dichotomy and if i say to my wife where
do you want to go to for dinner and she
says i don't care where you want to go
and i say oh i'm actually open for
anything i had a late lunch so i'm not
that hungry and i know you haven't eaten
today so
whatever you want it's good with me and
then she says no i
you make the call
right i mean how long may you do that
for before i say cool sounds like we're
going to raglan's
right
right and then she's going to go i i
didn't want that okay cool what did you
want then
i actually wanted whatever so would it
be
based off that hypothetical scenario
would it be actually even wiser to have
not just
maybe like three to four different
options maybe pre-contemplated
that kind of follow her interest a
little bit too yeah yeah uh you know you
can you can
she's wanting to make you feel like it
was your call
so then you just say hey how about we go
to
whatever the place that you know she
likes and she goes oh okay that'd be
great cool we're done we're good yes no
big deal so moving on because i feel
like i don't even want to read that much
into this we don't i don't make it
listen to that big of a deal well i feel
like it kind of can be sometimes that's
the thing it definitely can be
and not so much the restaurant thing i'm
saying in general so like you know how
okay so here's a common thing in um
in my household where you know you know
it becomes 4 30 5 o'clock right so here
comes mrs charles saying hey what are
you thinking for dinner now usually
that's your jam usually she kind of hey
i'm thinking this for dinner i'm always
pretty much always gonna be like good
you know why because i don't have any
preference i don't want to
make that decision i'm thinking about
other stuff to be honest is it a big
deal no it's not a big deal but i am
thinking about this stuff it makes it a
lot easier for my brain
as people as it may be to not have to
make that decision right
now i do understand that sometimes she's
in that same boat too because she was
thinking about a lot of stuff and
sometimes not all the time actually
not most of the time but sometimes she
doesn't want to make that decision as
well okay she'll make the dinner yeah
but she doesn't have to think something
up that everyone's gonna like and i
understand right
so that's the thing it can be a thing so
sometimes
people do just want you to make the
decision cool let me make one see no big
deal yeah no that's not
that's not what i'm just saying but you
got a balance i mean
i hate to go this hard and spend this
much time but like
if my wife says to me
know where do you want to go yeah and i
say where i actually want to go yeah and
she doesn't want to go there i can just
look at her face and be like oh well
that that's a bad call mm-hmm so i'm
probably gonna say actually i feel like
going to name one of her three favorite
restaurants and then we're good to go
there you go see but that takes some
pre-contemplation you got to know them
not really i don't have like a bunch of
different restaurants
either one of us doesn't have some big
list
the funny thing about my wife is she'll
be like she'll she'll
stray
from the
lesson learned which the lesson learned
to me is the lesson learned to me is
i'm going to a restaurant that i already
know that i already know what i'm going
to get and i'm going to get what i
already know yeah like that's my that's
what i'm doing yeah i'm going to the
restaurant that i know and i'm going to
get what i already know my wife will
sometimes she needs to relearn the
lesson which is oh she want to try this
new place so i'll go to a new place with
her yeah and then as soon as she takes
her first bite of the main course
she's looking at me like lesson learned
again right
so let's face it
now occasionally do you find a winner
of like a new restaurant to put in the
mix sure you can find that new
restaurant to put in the mix but it's
not very what do you mean what do you
mean okay okay i'm not saying whatever
like that's not true because it's
probably true but i'm saying what do you
mean it's probably true how often do you
go to a restaurant you're like oh wow
put this one in the mix
me
i don't know i don't know but that was
true you'd just be going to hundreds of
restaurants you'd have a list of
hundreds of restaurants that you'd be
going to all the time
because every restaurant you go to is
just in the mix now yeah to me all sushi
restaurants with the exception of two
are in the mix yeah it's true but my
point is but hold on hold on
there is there a hierarchy
yes
see so why if why would you not go onto
the top three to five at the most oh
there's there's
the hierarchy isn't based on like how
good it is oh then it's based on other
stuff but it's basically close to my
house i'm getting delivery maybe some
price scenarios and you know all this
stuff that's how the hierarchy is based
okay so the hierarchy is there so why
are you playing around because that's
not the point the point isn't what i do
specifically necessarily what you do
specifically because we're both in
unique situations i think i'm saying
generally
you don't think there's other dudes out
there that go out for dinner with their
wives sometimes that makes us unique oh
that part isn't unique okay
the part that you freaking you got your
one restaurant and your wife is that
certain like way that's i think the
typical person
there's more to it than that that's what
i think you know i know that i'm not
normal
right
i know so i know that it's not normal to
just be like oh
well i want to go to the same three
restaurants over and over again and get
the same exact food by the way yeah i do
the same thing there's so rare that i
have the i can't even remember the last
time i thought to myself oh it'd be
great to go out and try something new
okay so well there's probably some
psychologist doing an assessment right
now as i'm talking and figuring out like
oh he's got fear of
whatever and i don't think so i think i
just when i'm going to go out and i'm
going to invest like i already don't
want to get in a car i don't want to
drive somewhere i don't want to go wait
i don't want to put on shoes or whatever
yeah i'd rather just be barefoot right
so why are we doing this
well we're doing this because whatever
it's a good night you know my wife
doesn't feel like whatever we didn't
whatever she doesn't feel like whatever
okay so we're gonna go out somewhere so
i'm gonna go somewhere that i know yeah
that's cool they're gonna get something
that i already know good for you for
real it's unusable for the typical
person is what i'm saying hey let me ask
you this because i don't eat sushi how
much variance is there
in
quality yeah quality quantity
how can you say that you're not like you
got your top three
because the variance i don't care that
much about okay how often are you like
oh cool there's there's another one over
here let's go let's go order from that
one we've never been to before
not for the purpose of that it's new so
i agree with you in that scenario but so
this is what i am saying now
where
let's say okay have you ever heard of
the concept the idea i know you have by
the way of
someone say hey let's try something new
hey we always go there's my wife that's
my wife all day that's a lot of people's
wives and that's my point so sometimes
they want to try something new but they
don't want but sometimes they don't want
that beef of that decision they want you
to make the decision oh yeah so and so
so so sometimes just for the
just for the sake of it just to get some
leadership capital going yes hey let's
try something new we went to a joint the
other day that was new and you know what
it was
my wife was all excited you know like we
got in a car yeah we drove somewhere
okay and she was e-a-e man e-a-e
what is he everybody's all excited
so she was ea on this right and i'm like
okay so we went up there and we got in
there and it was like
it was uh
it and it was fine
and and now we're driving back after
finding parking after driving up there
finding parking
getting sat down
you know figuring out the menu and and
you were dry now we're now we drive home
and i'm like do you ever want to go back
there she's like no yeah
so think about that but that doesn't
mean that it was it's a bad way
right okay so so basically you're
hitting me what you're hitting me with
is i need to open my mind no no no no no
no that's true you should use that as a
flank you can flank me right now tell me
jocko you know what you just need to
open your mind you need to pry your
brain open and get some more different
food okay well i at this point in my
life i'm very uncomfortable telling you
what you should do i need help however
i'm done i'm actually with you with the
same restaurant same exact thing bro the
sushi restaurant that i call
pretty much every time i get sushi
unless it's the days that they're not
open literally and this is literally
i'll call they know my phone number
caller id it doesn't even say echo it
just says my number oh hi echo i say i
want this i want this one this and
they're like yeah like they know like oh
no keep coming on this they know the
thing in fact there was a new girl there
she's not new anymore
shout out to jocelyn by the way
um and she would be like oh uh she took
my order got it wrong the sushi chef got
it right on his own
that's how
you feel like you made it in the world
because of that right there you said
that with a lot of pride bro you're like
a lot of pride that is not the point the
point is
i'm with you on the whole i go the same
spot and get the exact same thing every
single time hundred percent my my
question was which you answered by the
way with your your uh your anecdote
is
sometimes
sure as a tradition not traditional as a
silent leader
you want to go with the other person's
plan but sometimes they don't want that
beef of even coming coming up with a
plan so you've got to have come up with
a plan
and it better not be the same exact plan
sometimes but here's the thing my wife
knows that if she asked me for a plan
she knows where we're going we're just
going to you know we're going to raglan
what up but hey here's the other thing
we already talked about this i
have to calculate the emotions in the
situation yes sir so
if my wife's like oh you know it's been
a long week i really just want to do
something nice tonight you know what
that means that means she wants to like
go to somewhere maybe we haven't been
for a big risk for me yes sir i know
what i got to calculate my my emotions
which can be controlled her emotions
which
i can't control but also
but also but also i'm gonna look at it
and say oh
my wife
is probably gonna be excited if we go to
a new venue that we haven't been before
so she's gonna be it's gonna be a
positive emotion for i put that in the
calculus i also have to put in the
calculus like i had hey my week was good
i'm not that busy whatever okay cool i
got some time tonight i'm not gonna be
mad so cool oh yeah it's a good night to
roll down there
and also if the calculus is my wife's
going to be super happy and i'm going to
be super angry that's no factor because
i can just be like cool i'm just going
to end force myself to have a good time
and no factor so i'm not going to i'm
not going to let it dictate but i have
to calculate the emotions on both sides
my emotions in the calculus
barely count
i'm going to say that again my emotions
in the calculus barely count and i don't
hold the grudge i don't mope around that
night i don't go to the restaurant and
say see i told you no
my emotions barely count what counts is
my wife's emotions or my employees
emotions or my boss's emotions i have
control over my emotions
therefore they have very little
little
say in the calculus i think i get it now
for real okay like okay correct me if
i'm wrong
because it's pretty if i if i got this
correctly i'm gonna talk it out and make
sure i got it it's pretty that was
pretty genius i think what you just kind
of demonstrated okay so in my scenario
hypothetical by the way where
my let's say i think my wife wants to go
somewhere new but she doesn't want to
think about where to go she doesn't want
to make the decision she doesn't want to
figure it out she wants me to go even
though i might not even want to go
somewhere new or maybe i do but i for
sure now don't they just go one level
deeper that's two conflicting plans
right there isn't it because her plan is
do something new right without having to
make the decision that's the plan
correct so it's like hey let's go with
that plan as opposed to my plan would be
like no we'll go to the same spot or no
i don't want to go that would be my plan
okay right so essentially just went one
level deeper where the decision to make
the decision is part of the plan that's
the decision yeah exactly right
i'm making a decision on a new place i'm
executing her
yeah so it's a win-win that's that's
what we're doing okay yeah yeah see you
see how nice
these things this is all works out in
the end bro that's the way it all is
it's all a unified theory
it's a unified do you know what a
unified theory is yeah it's like the
theory of everything yeah all the stuff
that i'm talking about it's a unified
theory and if you pull the threat on it
you'll be like oh
yeah so you are executing her plan and
her plan was to have you come up with
the plan okay so let me just this is a
new restaurant this is just me
echo telling you jocko this
um
the remember how i said like the the
number one most valuable thing not the
only one the number one most valuable
thing that i learned from you is
essentially the long game versus the
short game and how that's in play okay
so the updated version of that which
happened a while ago as well which is it
might be just more of the same really
but
basically it goes like this a more
unified uh expression
in life in everything you do whatever
pretty much there's gonna be a short
game being played and a long game be
being played most people that default to
the short game for sure but
it's going to be short game there's
going to be long game there's also with
everyday interactions with everything
you do there's going to be a small
picture and then there's going to be a
big picture
and i think that bigger picture like
that was an example of like just look at
it one level bigger bigger picture
where it's like you can't we're not
going with her plan to what restaurant
it is the decision
for the restaurant is part of her plan
yeah and just just just kind of fyi
saying the big picture yeah and saying
long term and saying strategy versus
tactics all those are interchangeable
not not completely interchangeable but
essentially interchangeable they're
different ways of saying the same thing
i mean when i would talk to one of my
guys i might not say hey think about
this from a strategic perspective i
might say hey you got to think about the
big picture and i'm not saying
a bigger map
right i'm saying over the longer term
so you're right
that it's a different way of expressing
the same thing
uh and maybe we could find some nuance
maybe we will find some nuances on the
big picture versus the long term versus
the strategy
but essentially they're all meaning the
same thing and they're all
a good place to focus
and you know
with that um
these are things that we're talking
about
to apply to
really everything that you do in your
life from picking restaurants to picking
employees to picking plans to figure out
where you're going to go in
six months and a year and two years to
to figure out what you're doing with
your own personal health
to figure out everything
and in order to do that
you have to detach that is the first
step that you got to take don't get
emotional listen to what people have to
say
keep your damn ego in check
it's there
we the hardest thing about the ego is
you don't know it it's it's like the air
that you breathe it's there and you
don't recognize it until you go oh hold
on a second
if you start to inhale something that
stinks then you notice it other than
that you don't really notice it that's
what's going on with your ego so you got
to be careful of it
and then
keep that mind opened
because that's that's
where you get the new ideas and that's
where you figure things out and if you
do that when you detach then your
ability
to see
will increase exponentially you can't
e it's like
if you
didn't have if you had bad vision
and one day you put on glasses
and you could see like that is
or or
you know one day you're walking around
you put some dirty chipped up
sunglasses on that were old and crappy
and you have sunglasses like that yeah i
got some sunglasses like that and and
you're just wearing them because it's
sunny out or whatever but there's
nothing really that you do you're just
cruising but then all of a sudden
something happens where you need to
see yeah and you lift up those glasses
and everything becomes real clear
that's like what detachment does it's
it's an amazing it's a superpower
and it gives you
an amazing advantage in everything that
you do so
everybody
that's what we got for you uh echo it's
a good way for us to get our minds right
what else are we uh what else we need to
think about here our buddies oh chad
never broke my foot i don't know if it's
broken but it seems bro you're wearing a
funny shoe yes called a post-op shoe
but you didn't get up no up just the
shoe okay i think it was like a turf toe
gone wild morphed into more injuries
because i i've been doing a barefoot
kind of scenario yeah you know when you
work out like squatting
and stuff i hear good things yeah and it
was working out for me yeah until well i
was until i was doing burpees on the
cement
going hard
so you know when you drop down and you
know burpees you can do them different
ways but i do the kind where like
they're almost like sprawls but i don't
sprawl on my hip or nothing
it's just on my hand
hands and feet that's it nothing else
touches so it's like there's some
pressure yeah the pressure barefoot
cement boom it hurts no problem was it
one impact you're like ouch no so it was
the whole the next day
of work yeah so the next day i was
jammed up but i could still do barefoot
squats and then the necks and actually
wasn't right the next day was like maybe
a day or two later
and bro the next day after that i was
couldn't walk
and my foot ballooned up
and it wouldn't go away bro anyway i'm
jammed up a little bit but
it does focus your brain on alternative
stuff you know what's what you've been
focused on the nutrition element i'm the
nutrition it's a big deal it helps with
healing way more night and day by the
way than sleep oh but yeah so yeah boom
that's what's going on with me
because i know you're wondering about
that anyway so
there is such thing as
exploring just nutrition but
supplementation
can be just as important
that percentage that people throw out
like on on
on nutrition versus exercise like you
can't outwork
a bad diet yes i i believe that that's a
good
for when you're
18 or 19 or 20 years old and you're
going through buds
[Music]
you're going to outwork a horrible diet
you can't
literally eat everything oh freaking
buds yeah scenario you can't out out-eat
a bud scenario yeah it's not happening
you just need to get your grub on yeah
that makes sense that's what you need to
do
uh yeah so if you want to help yourself
out get some milk
get some which is a protein dessert
really yeah all the things being
considered in my case it was uh
additional joint warfare additional
super curl oil that was my protocol
mocha have been going heavy on the mulch
it does
actually it jammed me up only with
cardio stuff
what oh the foot injury yeah yeah yeah
so i'm still going hard on the mulch is
the point there did you
did you see the little video i posted of
the the new factory down in north
carolina yeah what was your thoughts
what on the video of that new factor the
new factory well i know that the video
was you know freaking amazing yeah
that's what that's your assessment of
your video yeah yeah yeah
i don't want you to sit here and be like
well you know your angle on this channel
no i don't want your professional
assessment of the video there for you so
i watch
so i think so there's this guy named
jake tran he's he's a guy who makes
these really cool little mini like
documentaries almost on youtube and he
he talks about like conspiracies and
money and corruption and stuff that's
really interesting jake tran
and
so i go into rabbit holes every once in
a while with his videos so a lot of
times he'll talk about things like um
foreign corruption or like that's where
i got the um
actually it might have been from one of
these videos i'm not sure i forget but
where i got the expression uh uniquely
priced labor
uh okay so you get like
you know like and i get it man you want
to you know you know buy something kind
of cheaper and bring it you know and
sell it for more right and a lot of
times part of that discounted price is
slave labor the cost of making it
exactly later exactly right
you know do we do they say that when
you're making your order from china or
whatever do they say hey um you know
like here's all your your list items oh
labor uh
10 cents a day you know like it doesn't
say that kind of stuff so it's kind of
out of sight i don't mind let's face it
but yeah so when i watch your video in a
lot of videos actually the original hd
stuff it kind of like goes to show like
oh okay it creates this bigger picture
in your mind about what's really going
on like you don't
that guilt and i'm not saying everyone's
feels guilty about slave labor in other
countries but when you think about it
man it does warrant some guilt as far as
feelings go yeah for sure so yeah when
you see like yeah how you guys you know
origin and in that video and a lot of
other videos it kind of it does make me
think about that a lot more yeah and and
you know what else is an interesting
thing to think about is the environment
i was watching something oh i was
watching rogan the other day and i
forget who have on but they were talking
about seeing the
rivers
like a river in china and it's dyed blue
it's like blue
from making denim and they just dump the
chemicals right into the right into the
river and you can't live there because
it's so awful and polluted
and so yeah
that's why that's why we're doing this
man that's why we're doing this uh so
and it was cool the thing i liked about
showing that factory
that was my first time getting to that
factory
and the thing i i liked about sean is i
think it's a good opportunity for people
to go oh
oh i people are starting to understand
what we're doing why we're doing it
knowing that it's good for the workers
good for america good for the
environment good for you as a human so
originusa.com get yourself some gear
there and and you'll be stoked oh yeah
so also speaking of gear jack was a
store it's called jocko store some new
stuff on there
discipline equals freedom good oh we got
that and don't forget about the shirt
locker i talk about this all the time
but it is there's some cool if you're on
youtube is
a newer yeah
well you know what this is
that's gi joe right
yes
but yeah so they're a little bit
different kind of designs but you get
one every month yeah and if you can see
the layers i think that adds to the to
the experience
that's the hype oh yeah yeah what's up
jugglestore.com get some of that uh also
we have the jocko underground
we have to have that we have to have the
jock on the ground cause look we don't
control whatever platform you're
listening to this unless you're
listening to your own jocko underground
which you can do
then we don't control the platform we
don't know what they're going to censor
we don't know if they're going to insert
ads and force you to listen to an
advertisement
so that they can make money
involuntarily they make money off of us
and you yeah
and that's not good you don't need to do
that don't let them make money off of
you
come on
uh so yeah we don't and and we don't
know if they're ever going to just pull
us off because they don't like us
because we said something bad about
whoever
who said that we don't like slave labor
well they want to protect slave labor so
they pull us off the platform so
doctorground.com 8.18 a month and you
get this plus we do like additional
podcast on there
talking about things that are
let's say jaco podcast adjacent jason
life advice
and tips you know what would you
consider this is what i kind of thought
you know like you'll talk about like a
topic and a thought
you ever heard of the uh it's like a
book called deep thoughts it's more of a
comedy it's a joke yeah it's also like a
thing from saturday night live right
yeah and then there's a book there's an
actual book and it's just it's that but
it's a bunch of them and they're pretty
like some of them are like okay that's
funny but some of them are like oh yeah
huh and you know you kind of but these a
lot of times the beginning of jock the
underground podcast
is jocko's deep thoughts
that's interesting i didn't really
thought of that i don't think it is at
all
i think
what i think they are is like topics
that i come across where i think ah you
know that'd be cool to talk about for a
for half an hour or i learned something
that i go oh this applies to a lot of
different situations yeah it's not
really jocko podcast but
it's a little underground activity yeah
so there you go that's uh
jockowunderground.com if you want to
check that out we have a youtube channel
origin usa has a a
a youtube channel as well if you want to
check out what's happening
and uh dakota meyer he's got his thing
flipsidecanvas.com
if you want to get something cool to
hang on your wall i've written a bunch
of books you can buy you can read them
you can ask questions you can ask
questions about anything
on
extremeownership.com we have a a place
to learn leadership and a place to learn
about life really
i'm on there
one two three times a week live like a
zoom call well it's not like it's a zoom
call
if you wanna ask me a question directly
and you wanna have a full
interaction like hey explain the
situation and explain what you've
already tried and explain what this one
fred is doing and saying to you you can
work through all that stuff with me
go to
extremeownership.com for that and also
we have a leadership consultancy
go to salonfront.com for that
and
also
if you want to help service members who
are active and retired you want to help
their families you want to help gold
star families
mark lee's mom she's got an awesome
organization
and if you want to help that
you can go to america's
mightywarriors.org also our friend micah
he has a
incredible organization taking
vets out of the wilderness
to
to kind of reawaken
their soul
heroesandhorses.org
don't forget you can find us both on
twitter
on the gram on facebook echoes adequate
charles i'm at jocko willink
you gotta watch out for that algorithm
though it's gonna try and grab you you
know another thing if you wanna come and
meet up with us
come to the muster
we have a we have an event the next
one's in denver
so if you want to come to the muster you
want to hang out you want to meet you
want to go through some leadership
training
once again go to ashlandfront.com check
out events
and come to one of those live events
people ask me like oh
are you speaking live and those are
those are the events kind of where i
speak live the muster the battlefield
um ftx's i go to some of those so check
any of that stuff out
and of course
thanks to the military troops around the
world we just went through memorial day
and on that day we remember and
memorialized those that made the
ultimate sacrifice
and we know that all those
who signed the dotted line and swore the
oath made a commitment to make that
sacrifice so thanks to all of you out
there
who made that oath
and also thanks to
our police in law enforcement
firefighters paramedics emts dispatchers
correctional officers border patrol
secret service all first responders
you also
sign the dotted line and swear to
protect us
and we are grateful for your commitment
as well
and everybody else that's listening you
can't
see what you're doing
if you're
actually watching yourself do it if
that's the only thing you're watching is
what you're doing you can't see what
you're doing
you can't see where you're going you
can't see the impact that you're gonna
have you can only see a few inches in
front of yourself and you can't make
good decisions
when you can't see anything and you
can't make good decisions when you're
wound up and you're emotional
then you can't be a good leader or a
good person
if you're allowing any of those things
to happen and a lot of times what's
driving that
is your ego
so don't let your ego get out of control
take a step back
relax
look around
and then
go get after it
and until next time this is echo and
jocko
out